[Music]
all right just this week we learned that
prosecutors are nearing a decision as to
whether to charge this grace former FBI
deputy director Andrew McCabe but that
didn't stop fake News CNN from hiring
him fits in just perfectly with reaction
to that and what we expect coming out
tomorrow or very soon Senate Judiciary
Committee Chairman Lindsey Graham
senator good to see you first on the
hiring he wasn't he fired for lying and
leaking well I told you before that
compare the coverage CNN gave the Muller
report to the horowitz report so if you
have any doubt as to where these folks
are coming from and I've got some good
friends at CNN who try to be good
journalists but here's what happened
Sean cNN has just hired the alleged
architect of a criminal conspiracy
against the Trump campaign so how much
time and attention do you think they're
going to give the Horowitz report when
they hired the guy that Horace is
investigating let me ask you about where
so we have and we're expecting different
aspects as to roll out one we've
reported on this as John said a couple
of weeks ago first will be the Comey
report I expect it to be around 65 pages
some of my sources are suggesting it
will be pretty devastating as it will
say that he was not candid with the FBI
lack of candor that's lying that would
be what mana for Papadopoulos Flynn and
Kohner got in trouble for and actually
got charged with which Andy McCabe may
face and I have a problem if we don't we
don't apply our laws equally then the
next will be the Phi's abuse issue that
was the bulk of information there was a
class Lee Graham memo that said the bulk
of information in those applications was
Hillary's bought and paid for Russian
lies my question to you is how
devastated you said you believe this
will be devastating walk us through what
you think is going to happen yeah I
think it well what I think you're gonna
see is they a basically an attempt to
defraud the FISA Court that the dossier
is not verified to this day without the
steal dossier there would be no warrant
issued against Carter page I think
you're going to find pretty early
there was no real belief that
Papadopoulos was actually working with
the Russians and had no real contact
with the president but I want to repeat
what I said earlier on in the interview
cNN has just hired the person Horowitz
is investigating for committing crimes
against the trend the Trump campaign
Sinan has just hired the person Horowitz
is investigating how seriously do you
think they're going to take the Horwitz
investigation which is a really a shame
let me run through a series of quick
questions you if I committed
premeditated fraud on a court you think
I'd be indicted if you're an FBI agent
and you gave the court a documents you
had not verified and you said it was
verified you'd be in real trouble you
might be indicted but the day of
reckoning is coming to the DOJ and FBI
leadership who sought the warrant
against Carter page and opened up the
counterintelligence suppose you know the
probation workers on fire bowl and when
the FBI finally got around a building to
the shame it was not they even said 90
to 100 percent to this day is sun
verified and the counterintelligence
investigation there's no real credible
evidence I've seen to suggest that
Papadopoulos actually was working with
the Russians that came from our own
people that told him about the Clinton
emails the bottom line is who briefed
President Obama if anybody about the
counterintelligence investigation
against the Trump campaign and finally
why did they not tell the Trump campaign
that they had concerns about people
working for him tied to Russia that's
what you're supposed to do in a
counterintelligence investigation that's
what they did with Dianne Feinstein
would you agree with Andy McCarthy that
any counterintelligence investigation
has to have a president behind it and
struck and Paige referred to the White
House wanting to know every detail does
that mean that Barack Obama the
president at the time should be asked
what he knew and when he knew what about
all this
I can't imagine an investigation of the
Republican nominee for president
counterintelligence investigation of his
campaign was not approved at the highest
level
I cannot imagine it happening without
somebody in the White House knowing
about it and the question for me is who
told Obama and when you find out who
that person is you begin to put the
puzzle together do you think he needs to
be asked those questions sir
under oath absolutely if there's I'm
gonna call Tommy McCabe call me all of
them Brennan clapper
did you ever inform President Obama
about the counterintelligence
investigation what did you tell him when
did you tell him yes I'd like to know
what President Obama thought about the
the investigation why did not somebody
tell Trump the whole point of a
counterintelligence investigation is to
protect people all right senator Graham
good to see you thank you for being one